nurkic didn't do much there but he just
hit him in the head
and again now we see the trap and the
ball
is able to go to westbrook right at the
free throw line
this is when houston has success against
the traps on harden here's the soft trap
with mccullum
but they let the ball get to westbrook
in the middle of the floor
if you're going to have success with
those soft traps
you can't let him make that first pass
into the middle that is five fouls on
nurkic
free throws for russell westbrook when
we come back
in the fourth
nurkic the trip right here westbrook
going to the rim
but then afterwards stan russell
westbrook was hanging in the area the
portland bench damian lillard came over
russell basically gave hey i'm not
talking to him i'm talking about that
and the officials stepped in westbrook
is going to the free throw line
for a pair and nurkits remains in the
game for portland
yeah i think that the referee stepped in
there wasn't that much going on but they
know the history between these two guys
sure they don't want anything to get
going here
in these last seven minutes and 21
seconds
russell westbrook is five of ten at the
line
and misses on another